hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem combination sum
2 this is actually my second time making
a solution for this one cuz I think I
could do a little bit better than the
first time I explained this one so
before we start I want to mention that
this is part two of the combination some
series I would definitely watch part one
of this I have a very good video on this
you can also check it on N code iio if
you want to search for it this problem
and combination someone are a part of
the neat code 150 list which is a very
good list of problems to understand and
actually there's another problem that
will help you understand the trick
behind this problem it's actually an
array problem it's called threesome
that's also a part of the N code 150
list and it's beneficial to know for
this problem because we kind of
eliminate duplicate Solutions pretty
much the same way except we do so
recursively in this problem so let's get
into it the idea is we're given a list
of numbers and we want to find all
combinations from this set of numbers
that sum up to so similar to the first
question so one way would be 116 we get
this one we get this six and we get this
one they sum up to eight another one
would be 17 you could choose this one
and this one but couldn't we make up 17
multiple ways couldn't we also have
chosen the second one over here and the
Seven well technically they count as the
same combination so we don't want
duplicate combinations in the solution
set and another difference between this
problem and the first combination sum is
that we cannot use the same number in
unlimited amount of time so we can't
just take the one and reuse it eight
times to sum up to the Target we could
though use the same element multiple
times if it shows up multiple times in
the input we have two occurrences of one
so that's the max number of times that
we can use the number one in a solution
so that's what makes this a little bit
tricky in the first combination sum we
were given a distinct set of numbers and
we could reuse the same number an
unlimited amount of times so in the
first problem we had the input and we
were able to solve it very simply with
recursion for a given element either you
include it or you skip it so we would
have had 10 or we would have skipped 10
and then from here we would have chosen
from the next element we can either
include one or we can skip one from this
side though we're not quite at one yet
we can actually choose to continue
including 10 we can have multiple
occurrences of 10 or we could have
skipped it and in that case from here we
would have started choosing from one so
here we could have chosen uh one or we
could have skipped one and so that was a
very simple two Branch recursion but we
can't apply the same here and the reason
for that is at some point with this
example we might include one and then
eventually we might get to seven and
then we might include seven as well if
we were to have skipped this one we
could have gone down this path we could
have included the seven and then we
could have included the one that came
after it and we would have ended up with
duplicate combinations so we want to
avoid this case and we can believe it or
not still do so with two Branch
recursion it's going to be similar to
how we eliminate duplicates in threesome
so this is the trick behind eliminating
duplicates the issue here is that when
we choose to include one or choose to
skip one we don't want to end up with
another one on the same path where we
decided to skip one so how can we make
it so that we never see another one
again if we decided to skip it well this
is the trick first you take the input
array and you sort it so I'm going to
redraw this in sorted order now it's
sorted why did I put it in sorted order
because I want all duplicate elements to
be adjacent it's not necessarily
important that we go through the
elements in sorted order that's actually
not important because all of these are
going to be positive anyway so they're
always going to contribute to the Target
we're never going to deal with negative
numbers so it doesn't matter so much the
order that we go through them but it
does matter that we group similar
elements together so now I'm actually
able to make the choice I'm going to say
okay either I include one in my solution
set so this brand brch is going to
include all possible combinations that
include one or have multiple occurrences
of one up to two in this example or I'm
going to decide to skip one on this side
but when we are choosing from an element
we're going to obviously have some kind
of pointer that tells us the current
position that we're at let's call that I
so here I'm choosing between this
element I can include it and if I
include it here I definitely need to
shift my pointer because I'm not allowed
to reuse that same element multiple
times so I do have to shift the pointer
here so it's going to be shifted but
what about this case where I decided I
want to skip one well if I shift it by
one and it lands over here I'm still
able to choose from one but I wanted to
skip it all together so this is where
we're going to use something called a
loop I'm going to use a while loop and
what we're going to say is don't just
shift I by 1 keep shifting it while the
element at I is equal to its neighbor so
while these two are equal shift I so
right now I is going to be shifted over
here and right now this value is not
equal to its next neighbor so now this
is where I is going to land and when we
actually make the recursive call we're
always going to be passing in I + 1 into
the recursive call so we don't really
have to shift it again here so it's
already going to be passed in uh when we
do it recursively so that'll probably
make more sense when we get to the code
but keep in mind that just because we
have a loop in the recursive solution
doesn't mean we're going to be
recursively calling the function
multiple times we're still only doing
two Branch recursion so with this I'll
kind of run through the quick simulation
here and then we'll get into the code
the code is going to be very similar to
combination some one just the fact that
we're sorting the input this time and
that we're going to have a loop inside
of our recursive function so here we can
continue to include one we're at the
second one so here we could have
included it we would have gotten that
one one or we could have skipped it in
which case we're over here so we would
have you know still have been here but
just keep in mind that I'm not drawing
exactly where the pointer happens to be
um here we could like go through all
combinations obviously that's going to
be a very large tree but just trust me
when I say that eventually we could have
skipped two we could have skipped five
and we could have gotten to six and in
that case this would have been one valid
combination where we get 11 six so
that's going to be valid now another
base case could have been where we have
gotten to like 1 1 7 clearly in this
case we went over the target the target
should be eight but when you sum all of
these together we're going to get nine
so at that point we can actually stop
our recursion cuz we know all elements
in the input are positive so we're never
going to get a lower sum if our sum is
nine now but we're looking for a sum of
eight well we're never going to get
there at this point that's another base
case now from here you could imagine
that we would have skipped everything in
between here and we would have gotten to
seven in that case we would have gotten
1 7 that's another a valid combination
and I won't draw all of them out but
here we could have gotten to 1 2 five
that's another valid one in the case
where we skip one we could have chosen
two and then eventually chosen six so
that would have been another valid one
these are all the valid ones I didn't
draw out the entire recursion tree I
would encourage you to do that as an
exercise though I do think it'll help
you understand it and it might be easier
to kind of do the drawing after after
you look at the code so maybe that'll
help you out keep in mind the overall
time complexity of this is going to be
similar to combination some one even
though we're doing sorting and log in
that's not going to be the bottleneck
the bottleneck is going to be the fact
that we have up to two branches at every
single step assuming that every number
would be distinct in the input we'll
have two branches so the overall time
complexity is going to be something like
2 the^ of n that's how many different
combinations we could have ended up with
when we add these to the result we are
going to create a copy of every single
array so I think in the worst case the
time complexity would be n * 2 ^ of n so
not very efficient but given that this
is a combination problem there's no way
around that like the size of the
solution in the worst case is going to
be n 2 the Power of n so there's no like
shortcut in terms of time for us to
achieve the correct solution in this
case so you can't really apply dynamic
programming to this it's not going to
help you out in terms of the space if
you don't count the output as extra
space the over all memory is going to be
Big O of n for an individual combination
or for like the size of the recursive
call stack so I'm going to declare the
result it's going to be an array of the
combinations we know that that's what
we're ultimately going to return down
here so I'm just going to put that there
now we are going to have a recursive
function you could call it DFS or
backtrack I guess I'll call it DFS it
doesn't really matter we know that
there's a few things we're going to have
to keep track of one the current
position that we're at in the candidates
array two is the current combination
I'll just call that curve for short so
those are the elements in our current
combination and the third variable is
going to be the sum or the total of
those current elements so that we can
compare once the total has reached the
target amount or the total has exceeded
the target amount so before you even get
into this recursion remember that our
solution only is going to eliminate
duplicates if we sort the input array
that's the easiest way to do it so make
sure to call sort on the input array in
your language of choice it's pretty easy
in Python so I would highly recommend
using python I have a couple good
courses for that python for beginners
and python for coding interviews now
let's start with the base cases they're
pretty simple one we either reach the
target amount total is equal to the
Target amount two is the total exceeds
the target amount there's actually one
more base case though and that's what
what if we run out of candidates that
would mean our ey pointer is out of
bounds so either this is true or I is
greater than or equal to candidates and
it will usually just be equal to the
length of candidates so we can just put
that there so these are the two base
cases the second one is simple that's
when we just return we do not have a
valid combination and we never will at
this point this is where we do have a
valid combination so what do we do well
clearly we have to update the result so
I'm going to say result. pen to it not
just the current combination cuz that's
going to be a variable that we're
passing around by reference so we want
to actually create a copy of this one
way to do that in Python is like this do
copy again python is such a readable
language such an easy language to use
isn't it now don't forget within this
base case to return I mean I guess if
you didn't have the return it probably
wouldn't hurt but given that all
elements in candidates are positive if
we've reached the total sum everything
after this is just going to increase
that so might as well just put the
return here early now for the recursive
case and this is probably going to be
the complicated part so let me go a
little bit slow one is where we include
the element at indexi let's call that
candidates at indexi and the other is
where we skip candidates at index I so
this first case is pretty simple it's
similar to combination some one what
we're going to do is update our current
elements we're going to include the
element at index I and then we're going
to run DFS now for the index we're not
going to pass index I because that would
mean we're able to reuse the element at
index I but in this problem we're not
allowed to reuse the same element so we
have to put a plus one here we cannot
reuse candidates at indexi second we're
going to pass in the current combination
that's pretty straightforward and third
we're going to pass in the new Total the
total is just going to be the previous
total plus this element whatever this
element contributed to the total there
you go now after we're done with this
recursive call we're going to have to
undo the work that we just did and
that's pretty much as simple as removing
the element that we just appended to the
current so we can say current. pop
because of course in the next case we
want to skip that element so we have to
remove it from the current set of
elements now the next part I wish it was
as easy as doing this as easy as just
calling DFS on I +1
with the current combination with the
previous total since we're skipping the
element there's no need to update the
total I wish it was this simple but it's
not we require two more lines of code
and that is the loop that I was talking
about we want to say while the candidate
is at index I is equal to the candidate
at index I + 1 while that's the case
increment the pointer because I don't
want to use use the element at index I
and I don't want to use any duplicates
of that element either I want to skip
this element all together and the way to
do that is with this Loop like I showed
you the example where we had multiple
ones where we had one one and then we
had a two after it but it could have
been the case that we had more than that
we could have had like four ones or five
ones so we already recursively did the
path where we include one or more ones
now I want to do the path where we skip
all of these ones so that's why we need
the loop don't just skip this one skip
this this this this and this so that we
have a fresh choice to make there's one
issue with this what if we had an array
like this well I is always going to be
equal to the next element and then we're
going to end up with a comparison where
we compare this to the next element but
it doesn't exist make sure you have this
I + 1 is inbounds so that we don't get
an index out of bounds error when we
execute this part so that's very
important now this is the entire code
well I guess there's one thing that
we're missing if you're smart you'll be
able to notice it we defined our DFS
function but we never called it so let
me do that down here DFS what do you
think the parameters are going to be
well we're going to start at index zero
let's put that the current combination
initially is going to be empty so we can
have an empty array here and lastly our
total sum initially is just going to be
zero so let me put a zero there after we
call this function our result should be
updated and then we can and return the
final result so let me execute this and
as you can see here it works it is
efficient even though these run times
are pretty random maybe there are some
hacky ways that we can improve the
execution time but in terms of Big O
complexity this is the final solution it
is the most optimal if you found this
helpful check out n code. for a very
comprehensive road map and for a bunch
of courses that will make your life a
lot easier thanks for watching and I'll
see you soon